nick cannon you've got some explaining
to do
so you're having my baby i'm having
these kids on purpose
trust me that's a lot of people i could
have got pregnant that i did it
okay that's nick on his power 106 l.a
radio show breaking his on-camera
silence about having four kids with
three different women
in six months sometimes i have a little
bit too much fun in my life
and it gets me into a lot of trouble you
only live once
my kids call me a player i was like who
taught you that word
the 40 year old's always been open with
e.t about his love life
nick welcomed his seventh child zen with
wild and out model alyssa scott last
month
that's less than 10 days after having
twins zion and zillion with radio
personality abby dela rosa
in december cannon had his second kid
with ex brittany bell
he also shares twins moroccan and monroe
with mariah carey
you know me man family is a number one
priority
for me everything i do is calculated
god said be fruitful and multiply i'm
doing the lord's work out here
the mass singer host who is deeply
religious has said he believes
fatherhood is what he was put on this
earth to do
nick also told howard stern in 2017 his
outlook changed after developing
complications battling lupus
i'm probably going to die sooner than
most people
and that and because i mean that's what
that's what the doctor said but i'm
living life like no what did that
i might die in the morning all night
like
why where's condoms he now says
he was joking about not using
contraception and his health
is okay everything that i do you may not
agree with
but at least you can say i was real and
i was true and i was honest